Maria in New York City says what are the
wisest investments to make in my early
20s to retire by my early 30s so you're
talking about a really aggressive plan
to retire if it's possible yeah yeah I
mean see Kate's home what you think here
but I would ask first eyelash enough why
do you want to retire by your early 30s
if it's so you can sit at home and play
video games that it may not lead to a
meaningful life necessarily it might for
you but quite often what we do we think
of this mythical retirement well I'll
just be able to watch my favorite movies
of all time you could do that now you
don't have to retire in order so be able
to travel when I want right Ryan and I
aren't retired but maybe maybe were
technically are like we left the
corporate world we're not retired but
but Ryan and I have traveled more in the
last decades since leaving the coma
world without retiring than I ever
imagined I would travel retirement is
not the the magic bullet so ask yourself
why do you want to retire bye-bye
early 30s and if you have a good answer
for that great but if it's the rest on
your laurels guess what you're probably
not going to find a whole bunch of
satisfaction in doing so yeah yeah I
mean I agree so if you want to retire by
the time you're 30 here are a few things
that you're gonna have to do whether you
like it or not number one you're gonna
have to write down a list of the things
that you want to do when you retire
you've got to make a decision even if
you happen to find out that you're wrong
in the future you got to decide where
you're gonna live you got to decide what
kind of lifestyle do you want to have do
you want to live in a home are you okay
with living in an apartment when you're
30 do you want to be married do you want
to have kids but TK I can't make
decisions for my 30 year old self well
you're making a decision for your thirty
year old self right now by deciding at
20 that you want to retire so let's go
all the way with it where do you want to
live what do you want your lifestyle to
be because that's what's gonna help you
get your number there is no objective
number for retirement you can retire on
$450,000 if you want to live a certain
way is it might take you ten million
dollars to retire if you demand that you
live a certain way so you've got to get
that number make a long list of all the
dreams and the lifestyle details that
you need and then you've got to quantify
that an economic
terms that's the first thing know what
your number is if you don't know what
that is everything else is meaningless
and there's a lot of resources out there
like you can look at retirement
calculators there's many chris hogan has
one i know that in the fire community
which josh brought up on the minimal
episode there's a lot of resources out
there for you to help figure out what
that number is yeah there's this Mike
Murdoch quote I really like he says
prosperity is having enough of God's
provisions to complete his instructions
for your life that means one person can
be prosperous if they make six figures
another person can be prosperous if they
only make thirty thousand dollars are
you completing God's instructions for
your life so relative to your individual
mission the definition of wealth is
having enough resources to live the life
that you get to define as being
meaningful the second thing I would say
is if you want to be rich if you want to
get a lot of money that means you want
to get other people to give you a lot of
their money and there's only one proven
time-tested way to get human beings to
voluntarily reach into their pockets and
hand you their money it's a horde hands
and it's by a surgical mask the only way
to do that is to give them something
more valuable that makes them want to
part with that money so you've got to
make an investment in being a student of
humanity and getting really good at
creating value for other people and so
one thing I would pay attention to is
hey what are your curiosities and your
interests because if you're gonna be
working really hard to create value for
a lot of people you want to make sure
you're doing that in a way that you have
an advantage and that you're gonna enjoy
because if you're just focused on making
a lot of money you're gonna burn out
real fast because here's the open secret
about people we are really difficult to
deal with
and when we give you our money for
something we feel real entitled about it
you know we talk very differently if
you're five minutes late to pick us up
from the airport if you're our spouse
versus if you're the Oberer driver we
got different attitudes about things
when we pay money so if you're gonna be
dealing with people you've got a real
hard road ahead and you want to make
sure that you're dealing with them in a
way that is meaningful for you so you
want to make sure the process of getting
that money isn't governed by just the
need for money pay attention to your
curiosities pay attention to your
passions and go into business and
something that you can enjoy third
you've got to be better than the average
person in order to create the kind of
value that's going to help
retire at 30 you're asking for something
that is the equivalent of me saying how
do I make it to the NBA you need to be
better than just the average person in
basketball right you're asking me how to
make the Hall of Fame of finances you
can do it but it is the Hall of Fame and
you got to be real about what you're
going after so that means you're gonna
have to invest significantly in your
intelligence it's not about buying up
some stocks right now it's about buying
up some books and reading the heck out
of those books and being smarter than
just about everybody that you know yeah
100% man I think what what I feel like
Maria is asking is hey what's the next
Bitcoin that I can put my money in right
now that's where I buy 30 yeah and if I
had an answer Maria like I'd share with
everyone and I'd do it myself but we
don't have that answer the truth is is
if you're 20 you can't retire in your
early 30s but it's gonna take a whole
hell of a lot of sacrifices right now
I love no I love how you brought up the
fire community in the minimal episode
because there is a whole community out
there financial independence retire
early that is what fire stands for
there's a documentary out there we have
a Shakespeare on the podcast yes there
are so many resources out there that
people talk about doing exactly what
Maria wants to do and what I love about
this whole fire community is there is no
easy answer there are simple answers a
lot of simple inches but simple is not
easy in Maria if you want to retire at
30 you're gonna work your ass off you're
gonna you're gonna dedicate the next 10
years of your life to virtually putting
yourself in a poverty situation na na
what do we what do we call it in a
restricted your restricting yourself you
are temporarily depriving yourself
you're gonna put yourself in a situation
of depravity in order to get there but
you can do it okay totally or or here
here's here's the simpler solution not
easy a simpler solution redefine what it
means to retire yeah because right now
Riot I owe I will often tell people I
retired at age 30 yeah me too and and
they're like oh were you set financial
no no no I start to do things to make
money but I left the corporate world and
so I redefined what it meant to be
retired and meaning I still have to do
things to earn a living but it's no
longer about you know doing the thing
that I dislike so I can make enough
money to maintain a lifestyle that
wasn't even bringing me joy in the first
place